- [Instructor] We are in the year 1095.
Just for context, this
is roughly half a century
after the Great Schism between
the Eastern Orthodox church
in Constantinople, or
centered at Constantinople,
and what eventually gets known
as the Roman Catholic church,
or the Latin church, centered at Rome.
We have the Byzantine Empire
continuing to lose territory.
Remember in the 7th century
as Islam expanded out over Arabia,
it quickly overran much of the territory
in the Holy Land that at the time
was controlled by the Byzantines,
Byzantine being another word
for the Eastern Roman Empire.
By the time of this map,
Islam had been in control
of the Middle East,
the Holy Land, North Africa,
and even a good chunk
of the Iberian Peninsula
for several hundred years,
as much as over 400 years.
As we get closer to this time period,
you have the Seljuq Turks
continuing to eat in
to the Byzantine Empire
and taking most of the
Anatolian peninsula.
Also at this time, remember,
we are in the high Middle Ages,
which is a time when,
especially western Europe,
is on the rise.
There's increased
agricultural productivity,
the population is increasing.
And it's in this context
that the emperor of the Byzantines,
the emperor of the Eastern Roman Empire
looks for help.
Emperor Alexios I sends a delegation,
sends an ambassador to Pope Urban II,
and he essentially asks
for some mercenaries
to help him retake some of Anatolia
from the Muslims.
Well, Pope Urban II sees
an opportunity here.
It's been roughly half a century
since the Great Schism.
He has his own internal struggles going on
and struggles with some
neighboring states.
He sees this, potentially,
as an opportunity
to focus attention elsewhere.
And so later that year,
in November of 1095,
he makes a sermon at Claremont
in the kingdom of France.
There are varying accounts of his speech,
but this is one of them.
I, or rather the Lord, beseech you
as Christ's heralds to
publish this everywhere
and to perse, which is
another way of saying
to persuade, all people of whatever rank,
foot soldiers, and knights, poor and rich,
to carry aid promptly to those Christians,
so to the Byzantines,
and to destroy that vile race
from the lands of our friends.
When he's talking about vile race,
he's talking about the Muslims
who have control of
the Anatolian peninsula
and of the Holy Land.
I saw those to those who are present.
It is meant also for those who are absent.
Moreover, Christ commands it.
And according to this account,
he goes onto say, all who die by the way,
whether by land or by sea, or
in battle against the pagans,
shall have immediate remission of sins.
So this is this idea of indulgences,
where hey you do something for me,
I can forgive your sins.
This I grant them through the power of God
with which I am invested.
O what a disgrace if such
a despised and base race,
once again he's talking about the Muslims,
which worships demons,
should conquer a people
which has the faith of omnipotent God
and is made glorious
with the name of Christ.
Pope Urban II's speech has an impact
larger than even he expects.
Throughout Western Europe,
news of his speech,
news of his call to go
and retake the Holy Land,
to fight against this
despised and base race,
the Muslims, takes hold.
And before the Pope is
even able to organize
a formal army, you have
someone by the name
of Peter the Hermit lead what's called
the People's Crusade in 1096.
And this is often considered
the first part of the first crusade.
As they march through the Rhineland
in what is now Germany,
they massacre Jews, several thousand,
calling them Christ killers
on their way to the Holy Land,
and this is a theme that you will see
throughout the Crusades.
Even though the crusaders
ostensibly were there
to help the Byzantines,
ostensibly to take back
the Holy Land, as they
travel through foreign lands,
they often wreak a lot of havoc,
even sometimes on the
Byzantines themselves,
but the People's Crusade itself
was very unsuccessful.
By the time they got to
the Anatolian peninsula,
remember, Peter the Hermit was leading,
there were women, there were children,
there were untrained peasants fighting,
they were massacred by the Turks
when they got to the Anatolian peninsula.
But eventually, the Pope
was able to organize
a more formal, what eventually gets called
First Crusade, and once again,
it surpasses the Pope's expectations
and far surpasses Alexios,
the Byzantine emperor's expectations,
and it's even a little
bit frightening to him
where you have on the
order of 100,000 soldiers
coming from western Europe
taking these various routes
by both land and by sea.
And in 1099, they are eventually
able to take Jerusalem
from the Muslims, and both
in their taking of Antioch
and Jerusalem, most historical accounts
say it was quite bloody
with significant chunks of
the cities being massacred.
This is a later image of what
it might have looked like
when they conquered Jerusalem.
And from that time period
through most of the 12th century,
they maintain control of the Holy Land.
This is what the map looks like in 1135,
and you might notice some changes now.
The Byzantine Empire has reconquered
chunks of the Anatolian peninsula,
in particular the west and the north,
and you see these blue regions here
which are known as Crusader Kingdoms.
We can zoom in on these Crusader Kingdoms,
or Crusader states, and
what's interesting about them,
even though these western
European crusaders,
now they weren't called
crusaders at first,
but they wore a cross on their outfits
and were eventually called crusaders,
even though their goal at first
was apparently to help retake land
for the Byzantines, when they
were able to take the land,
for the most part, they kept it.
And they set up these Crusader states,
or these Crusader kingdoms
that you see right over here
that they're going to stay in control of
for most of the 12th century.
As you get into the middle
of the 12th century,
the Muslims are able to take back
a few significant cities,
which is going to catalyze
the Second Crusades,
but then as we get to 1187,
the Muslim ruler Saladin is
able to take back Jerusalem,
which as we'll see in the next video,
will instigate the Third Crusade.